(upbeat horns)
- Hi, my name's Frank Castillo,
and I'm here to tell
you about Cinco de Mayo,
or as us Mexican millennials
call it, CDM Five.
(soft music)
Cinco de Mayo is
a Mexican holiday
commonly confused with
Mexican Independence Day,
which is actually a movie
starring Danny Trejo.
(laser explosion)
In Mexico, Cinco de Mayo
is celebrating the day
the Mexican Army
defeated the French Army
in the Battle of Puebla.
But I mean, who hasn't
whooped France's ass?
(cheering crowd)
Not a lot of
Mexican-Americans know
the origin of Cinco De Mayo.
Because they don't
want to get deported.
Instead, it's more
of a celebration
of Mexican culture, in general.
But I'm not Mexican, how do
I celebrate Mexican culture?
Do I wear a luchador mask?
A sombrero?
Fight a French guy?
No!
That's Cinco de
super-depressing.
The best way to celebrate
is by eating Mexican food.
- [Children] Yum.
- Or churros.
Just a fried stick of
dough covered in sugar.
It's like a really lazy donut.
Interesting fact, Mexicans
don't believe in diabetes.
But Frank, I'm not a foodie.
I'm just looking for
any cultural holiday
as an excuse to get drunk.
Well, if you have to drink,
make sure it's tequila.
You can only make
tequila in Mexico,
and only real Mexicans
can handle tequila.
Happy Cinco de Mayo everybody.
(chokes)
Oh my God, that burns so much.
(upbeat horns)